et complètement épuisé cela se comprend
très bien amoureuse de la littérature
depuis toujours elle espère profiter de
la pandémie pour se lancer dans
l'écriture
on peut pas vraiment aller à des
spectacles sortir voir des gens alors
c'est le moment idéal pour terminer un
projet et s'est tourné vers l'auto
édition pour publier son premier livre
un témoignage personnel sur son
expérience de projets dante
ce que j'aimerais c'est que les gens qui
s'intéressent à toute la question du
consentement anticipé pour les gens qui
souffrent de troubles cognitifs puisse
bénéficier de ce témoignage là pas de
doute elle a eu la piqûre
elle travaille déjà sur un projet du
livre pour ses petits enfants
de plus en plus dota font le choix de
l'autoédition leur nombre presque doublé
en 10 ans passant de 340 et au québec en
2009 à 668 en 2018
une tendance s'est accentuée avec la
pandémie et avec la belle lancée par
janette bertrand
tous les gens qui savent ce qu'ils
pensent qu'ils sont pas capables qui
pensent que l on faire des fautes
d'orthographe sa compo on l'écrit pour
soi ou québec se spécialise dans l'auto
édition
ici on a observé une hausse de 15 à 20%
au cours de la dernière année
ceux qui hésitaient un peu ce qu'ils
savaient pas très bien comment faire
donc on a eu effectivement une
augmentation des gens à la retraite qui
avait un projet qui dormaient dans leurs
placards plus ou moins elle met
cependant en garde les aspirants auteurs
leurs projets d'auto édition doit être
motivée par la passion et non par
l'appât du gain
c'est sûr qu'on fait pas d'argent mais
ça c'est certain
oui ce qui motive les gens c'est de
sortir leurs livres et puis de
d'accoucher de leur projet puis tant
qu'on n'est pas passé par lens s'en rend
pas compte mais c'est vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de satisfaction de fierté aussi
un bonheur que vient de découvrir
jacques le faire
l'univers a commencé à 78 ans il vient
de publier pour la première fois on fait
tous des des choses importantes dans les
vies témoigné ccc laisser une trace
ce qui n'était qu'un simple passe temps
est devenu un vrai livre de qualité
professionnelle toute petite petite
affaire mais c'est là alors bon ben ça
ce sera ma ma petite goutte d'eau dans
l'océan des pensées huet ici nabi
alexandre charti radio canada montréal